un mouvement de grève qui a concerné
aujourd'hui également saint quentin en
yvelines les fonctionnaires étaient dans
la rue pour une journée d'action motifs
protester contre les mesures annoncées
par le gouvernement
suppression de 120 mille postes de
fonctionnaires d'ici la fin du
quinquennat rétablissement de la journée
de carence gel des salaires bonsoir
bertreau mesure qui est avec nous par
téléphone bon port elle vous êtes co
secrétaire du syndicat d'enseignants fsn
uip et pfs eu donc dans les yvelines
vous étiez dans le cortège à paris ont
manifesté aujourd'hui 26 mille personnes
selon la préfecture de police
45000 selon la cgt alors on ne va pas
faire une bataille des chiffres mais
quel est le bilan finalement en cette
fin de journée est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de cette mobilisation va
écouter dans les plus belles voix pour
défendre l'intérêt général et en ce sens
cette journée a été positive les fait
pas ou peur de ce qu'on aurait souhaité
mais en tout cas elle était très
politique
alors c'est la première fois depuis 2007
que neuf syndicats appelaient à la grève
aujourd'hui c'est c'est une force quand
on voit par exemple que dans le secteur
privé pour la manifestation contre la
réforme du code du travail les syndicats
n'arrivent pas à s'unir là c'est une
force aujourd'hui que vous ayez fait
front commun à l'écouté je crois que qui
est caractéristique
en interne la fonction publique fait que
manifestement gouvernement souhaite
s'attaquer à l'intérêt général et la
fonction publique est là pour défendre
et pour participer à cet intérêt général
vous a pas échappé que les dernières
mesures du gouvernement visait plus à
favoriser une chapelle catégories de
personnes dont deux sont partis ni les
fonctionnaires et les salariés en
général qui ceux du privé sont attaqués
particulièrement violemment concernant
la vie de la loi travail
mais côté vitesse qu'on a une idée des
personnes mobilisées
- du côté de votre syndicat à l'écouté
moi j'estime entre 25 et 30% la
mobilisation sachant que les chiffres
qui sont annoncés par les autorités ne
sont pas fiables dans la mesure où ne
sont pas comptabilisés les enseignants
qui ne sont pas remplacés où elle est
par exemple époque du second degré et tu
commentes après 8h alors les motifs de
la protestation les rappels suppression
de 120 mille postes de fonctionnaires à
d'ici la fin du quinquennat
rétablissement de la journée de carence
gel des salaires des salaires dernière
question qu'exiger vous concrètement
c'est une marche arrière du gouvernement
vous souhaitez nous ce qu'on souhaite
avec la fonction publique devienne ce
qu'elle a été pendant les trente
glorieuses
c'est à dire l'assurance pour l'ensemble
des personnes de tous les citoyens
français d'avoir des services publics de
qualité
merci bertrand mesure d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes le
cosecrétaire de snuipp-75 l'hymne ô